wohin er ist einfach ärgerlich ist ein
paar den kopf einfach den kopf nimmt
kommt ist ja nicht mehr wirklich mit
seinem körper verbunden irgendwie
komisch
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
hero zusammen mit zombie dabei hallo ich
bin auch mal dabei weil ja ich hab halt
die kripo farben und einer seiner
letzten folge nicht unbedingt perfekte
in tokio wo bekommt nicht so wie ich
wollte ja ich hatte mir ja schon mal
weißes trikot geholt und jetzt habe ich
mir ein schwarzes geholt wie alt bei mir
eine letzten folge gesehen habt und da
steht wenn ich damit meine show coupe
die richtig drauf mache steht der zombie
und anstatt dass sich das jetzt tut und
wir irgendwie neues wohl oder so weil
ich einfach mal den song gefragt woran
das liegt an der meinte dass es daran
liegt dass es eigentlich dass er deshalb
gezähmt hat aber wir beide gleichzeitig
auf dem server sein müssen damit er hier
da so dass irgendwie so umwandeln kann
er sich auf sich umschreiben ja
überhaupt
ich komme einfach zu dir kurz so etwa
mir fehlen voll viele blöcke irgendwie
am haus also ich habe schon drei blöcke
gesehen die vielen ist es irgendwie vom
ändern wenn aber ich wollte
wahrscheinlich um 10.8 cool du hast du
auch schon die wege gemacht weil ich war
dabei vor dem haus kinder vor dem haus
ist eine lücke ich konnte mir rein mit
meinem kampusch trivial regal einzige
was nerve deshalb die eingänge müssen
irgendwie umgebaut werden dass alles
passt wieder
aber vielleicht werde ich auch noch
umziehen und wer dann mal in meinem haus
dann irgendwie nochmal ne
gesonderte farm machen mit ganz vielen
kisten weil ich bin ja farbigen typ hier
in der stadt da wäre ich dann die ganzen
essens sachen rein sondern wie das eine
sternschnuppe den frust irgendwie unter
dem turm ist abgestürzt
januar scan die post eigentlich freeride
ich hab nämlich relativ viel was ist
frieden wright des designs meteor woraus
man werkzeuge bauen kann man die man
verzaubern haben ja das möchte dafür
haben ich kann der mexikaner tanzen
geben ist trocken hier ist bei mir total
verbuggt der kopf hängt irgendwie voll
daneben ja auch schon heute fallen
ich habe dann einfach dahin die genannte
glücklich bin werde ich habe ihm gesagt
er seinen kopf hochnehmen kommt nur kopf
junge hexe und nämlich schon zu beginn
die er ist einfach ärgerlich ist einfach
den kopf weg geht einfach den kopf der
kopf ist ja nicht mehr wirklich mit
seinem körper verbunden irgendwie
komisch ja erstmal ein goldenes bitte
erstmal eine zombie gold rot gefärbt von
morgen das goldene k
deswegen dachten russ bedrohte vergeben
und heute gesehen ganze und wer morgens
seminar am start das kann fliegen
sicherer halt schauen wenn ich wieder
runter gehe einfach du kannst
besteuerung bringen ja wie geil ich bin
ich damit schnell kommt nie wieder
es ist recht schnell doch egal
die kuh mit dem schwarzen schopf night
vision wenn du drauf sitzt ja ja ich
habe mit meiner triebel rüstung night
vision die ganze ist kein unterschied
ich werde mir vielleicht noch das gerüst
zu machen weil heute schwarze hier wäre
gar nicht gezähmt gewesen zum beispiel
siehst du immer einem halsbändern
schwarzer hättest du dir sowieso nehmen
können ach verdammt ich habe das andere
genommen was ist das ja bei mir zu hause
hier wieder hingelaufen wolltest mir
diese behinderten zeigen gezeigt hast
hast du hast du samt bisschen kenner
monster hiermit teilen wir hier so
reinkommt ich mit meinem nachkommt hatte
so jetzt gehen mal kurz rechts
ja das ist ja also ein bisschen nur noch
15 ich bin grad eingezogen hierdurch
helfen
ok casting tunnel in deinem garten ich
nicht
in china konnte exakt ist okay wenn ich
sachen er gehört dir hast du ja ja ich
habe jetzt einfach um den abend anzeigen
lassen oder direkt an zu regnen
ob das noch nicht gut und was ich auch
noch sagen wollte wie mache ich da eine
back dran ein schoko backpack weil sie
nicht den halbleiterbereich gehabt so
kann ich ja elfjährigen rechtsweg drauf
zog der wert nur dropbox ich nicht mal
hoch ja das ist hier so einen solchen
hier aber ich kann damit nicht recht
machen können da nicht drauf machen
bei technisch war zu wenig da als mich
theoretisch ist drauf setzte es gibt
schoko beck packs und schoko pro sattel
becks in ordnung wenn ich herausfinde
werde ich zu schreiben
ok cool aber ich kann mit dem juke
worauf man dann drop dir machen aber der
hat ja ja aber jetzt hat er das backpack
aber keinen sattel mehr
na ja und es gibt eben eine kombination
aus beidem scheinbar noch den sattel
backpack ehrlich ja oh warte man muss
wahrscheinlich den server bank ich habe
den weg gemacht
ach man ja vor du kannst bei der türkei
wo noch machen dass der name angezeigt
wird wenn du auf das neben hintendrauf
kriegst dann sieht man ja noch über den
feed okay gut
der kostet jetzt uns ein paar noch
weiter und ich möchte dem hat bei mir
hier auf und wird es dann zusammen
schneiden bei mir geht es normal weiter
und ich bin der stadt weiter genau ich
war schon mal über den rest kontrakt von
kraft als ihr wollt schaut auf seinen
kanal oder anderes von zombie sehen
wollt dann schaut doch als zombies kanal
jetzt weg deswegen nicht ganz jetzt
jetzt jetzt geweckt
braucht ihr auch spaß noch so zum ist
weg das heißt ich gehe es mal ganz gut
schlafen da nächstes nicht mal nachts
das heißt ich kann nicht schlafen gehen
das dorf
so wie mache ich das jetzt ich wollte
jetzt auf jeden fall seine backpack
machen das erstmal danke zombie dass der
java ich brauche 13 leder und mehr
brauche ich gar nicht das ist doof weil
ich hab mir gedacht als das andere geht
schwieriger zu kräften kann ich dann
auch es hat dann irgendwie mehr vorteile
oder so
bestimmt nicht ich brauche dann wohl
doch diese seite aber dann habe ich auf
jeden fall in anderen sattel ich das
machen und dann hat mal so drop gibt mir
das mal so kurszettel
a
jetzt geht das und jetzt kann der
besucher des kanals machen kann jetzt
endlich auch man dieser platte regen
nervt aber auch job g s day confirm ken
read so das kannst du doch die kirche
nicht [ __ ] ich nicht hayes hat der
tasche neueres heißt das jetzt was ist
wenn ich mein ganzes inventar sagen wir
mal ich hab mein ganzes inventar voller
pfeile so nah liegt derzeit bei rum und
ich setze jetzt auf meinen job drauf und
reiter über den pfeil heißt da was heißt
das jetzt
dieses blöde all das ist blöd dass ich
in linx hatte wenn ich doch jetzt so
mache top gear das heißt ich habe jetzt
ja ich mache das hier mal wieder
zusammen nehmen
das ist jetzt doof wenn man wie man
sitzt ja aber das war ja alles nur aus
testzwecken meine lieben freunde so und
so auch der der sattel
er vertrat daraus gedroppt also das ist
cool aber das ist jetzt dass ich mit
ihnen gemacht haben schoko backpack aber
naja muss ich jetzt mit lebende jockeys
auf jeden fall wieder am start jungs
wenn zombie meinte er dass wir eventuell
auch irgendwie dann bald man goldene
haben also eine goldene farbe hat jetzt
zeit 1 er versucht noch ein zweites aus
zu kriegen dann keine liebe miteinander
paaren meinte der das mw davon dann auch
eins geben wird und was ich machen
wollte ist ich hab zwar gerade erst
dieses haus hier gebaut
allerdings wollte ich eventuell umziehen
nach da vorne weil ich finde dass ist
einfach zentraler näher kommen wir
können es mal gucken die
immobilienpreise ich meine hier werden
wir übrigens mittlerweile auch blöcke
geklaut da fehlen blöcke da vorne
fehlten blog hier fehlte auch irgendwo
einen zaun und da drin fehlt auch noch
im wohnblock und ich weiß nicht ich habe
es irgendwie lieber will nicht so ein
bisschen im stadtkern wohnen deswegen
auch wenn ich später irgendwie umziehen
möchte ich möchte erstmal zentralen der
face camp sitzen möchte ich auch nicht
irgendwie am arsch der welt wohl von
ingolstadt sondern auch wenn schon
relativ zentral und ich finde will
müsste ich wohne da und die anderen
wohnen alle da und ich will halt relativ
weit weg
deswegen wollte ich dann theoretisch
mein standort hierhin versetzen hier
einfach dass ich hier dann irgendwie
gegenüber von kfz- oder so und hier dann
quasi man das haus dann hin bauen
deswegen werde ich das wahrscheinlich
dann einfach hierhin bauen und so ein
bisschen im flair der stadt roth also
ich hab das ja eh schon von anfang an
bei mir so gemacht dass ich das mit
diesem helm
dem dunklen holz ein bisschen geparkt
habe sonst ist das ja alles irgendwie
also wie zombie dass davon hat aus
diesem holz aus diesem redwood sachen
finde ich auf jeden fall cool auch käfer
dass auch wir haben das alles mehr oder
weniger okay dann ist es sehr schön
das werde ich auf jeden fall machen dass
ich dann hier ins ziel
und ja ich weiß jetzt noch schaffen wie
sind bei neun minuten
bisher habe ich nur geschafft mit zombie
scheiße zu bauen
das war's also ich hoffe mal dass ich
das noch irgendwie geht jetzt da oben
alles weg das wäre natürlich
wünschenswert mich auch jetzt hat er mir
auch gar nicht so friesen leid sachen da
gegeben
der dorf man hat dem er gar nicht
gegeben so ich stelle mir vielleicht
einfach ein schild neben kulturellen
werte vielleicht hat kepler irgendwas
geschrieben auf meinen papier
geschrieben nur vier mitarbeitern ok
-magazin hat nichts geschrieben gut wann
er auch ein paar sachen war hält sich
viel wissen ich mache mir eben oder soll
ich mir ich glaube also ich brauche
jetzt mittlerweile echt viel von diesem
dings viel von gute achse und sowas gibt
es rüstungen hier gibt es waffen und
gadgets mineralien mob drops holz und
kraft nein steinzeug dreck hier ist ja
nur sein portal zu simon leute ich
glaube ich habe ich einen ofen jahr der
ja doch ich abrufen zumal ich möchte
diese doofe regen jetzt aufhört also aus
meinem haus
wenn ich dann ich mache jetzt erstmal
drei schilder zwar schreibe ich hier ein
schild denn hier entsteht konkret dass
neues haus da mache ich bei mir ins haus
ein schild und forsthaus und schild und
schreibt dahin die entsteht die
öffentliche essens hügel nach einem
sammelstelle dingsbums teil
ja und dann werde ich halt hier
entziehen und ich hoffe einfach mal ist
es alt geil wird also dass ich hier auf
jeden fall ein schönes haus machen kann
was den anderen häusern hier würde ich
mir die aufstehen weil das dauert mir
gar nicht zu lange da denke ich jetzt
lieber darüber machen wir dann
allerdings axt und fand ich das amt viel
besserer bürgermeister als kilo schwere
gegen wie die weg und so runter fährt
schön ja dann kommt hier einfach die es
in sammelstelle hin dass ich da noch ein
bisschen umbauen und soll dann hier
einfach die wand rausreißen komme ich
mache jetzt erstmal hier ganz kurz
korps stück stück speck sticks so
manchmal eben reine axt daraus seine
spitzhacke dennoch eine axt schaufel
brauch ich glaube ich erst mal gar nicht
so so so die wand hier kommt raus und
dafür da kommt einfach nur sonnensonde
unterteilung dingsbums da rein
also einfach nur sowas acht es wird
glaube ich gerade nacht
aber ich sehe schon dass da hinten ganz
langsam wer nur noch 7 minuten manchmal
besser bei allen hier
da muss eigentlich eher dahin allgemein
muss dieser ganze weg eigentlich in
meinen garten mal zu kommen
furtado ich habe nur noch 20
dann ist krieg erwachsen geworden aber
man sieht schon dass clegg der typ da
draußen das weltkrieg ist er geistig
behindert das wissen wir alle und er
guckt einfach so behindern nach draußen
na gut
wir bauen allerdings den weg nach da
unten mal zu ich habe gar keine ernte
mehr sprechen dafür nehmen ich meine ein
paar sachen die brauche ich echt nicht
irgendwie cobblestone wie wär's mit
kumpels tisch kommt
denn er hatte schon ganz aufgeregt so
hier lang
und jetzt so ich weiß nich ist gerade
macht oder nicht
ach so das hier natürlich nur eben mit
so meine ich mag meine rüstung zwar
eigentlich aber ich glaube die scale
rüstung ist sogar noch besser
also wenn man das jetzt mal mit dem
dings hier gleich stellt night vision
habe ich auf meinem chocobo drauf ich
weiß nicht was die scale rüstung hat
muss vielleicht mal nachgucken aber ich
kann mir einfach noch mal alles geld
rüstung machen ich meine hexie kahles
setzen haben wir glaube ich genug
wir haben noch zehn wir brauchen nämlich
zum 6 man braucht rechts 16
gut dann brauchen wir noch zehn aber
vielleicht findet finden wir noch ein
paar ich hab letztens übrigens ein
übersehen das brauchte mir nicht alle
die kommentare schreiben
ich hab nur letztes eine waffe in das
tut mir leid weil wir wurden auch
richtig viele bäume gefällt
da wurden immer so die anderen gepflanzt
diese doofe dorf männer im märz kaputt
gemacht na gut das auf gar keinen fall
mehr schaffen da noch irgendwie wird hin
zu klatschen heute wir sind dieser folge
dann welches einfach in der nächsten
folge machten das holz brauche ich
eventuell kann ich auf dem pinken holz
machen dass sie durchaus was brauche ich
denn sonst noch sonst wie sonst
eigentlich gar nichts ich wollte
vielleicht kann ich hier aus kann ich
sogar red redwood slap davon braucht
nämlich auch ein paar bei den sachen die
ich vorhabe 30 glaubt sogar noch mehr
dann gehe ich jetzt mal schon mal rüber
ach die stelle wo ich das eben machen
management mensch vergisst ihr wieder
alles drei schilder
89 hier habe ich noch sagt loos vier
minuten noch
deswegen mache ich das jetzt einfach so
hier entsteht die öffentliche
essensausgabe von con crafter so dass
jetzt dahin damit ihr auch wissen weil
ich bin ja hier essens fritze
vollständig entziehen
hier entsteht das neue haus von con graf
daneben kev so eilig wieder gern im café
und jetzt auch eines für zombie ob denn
wir dann diese fressen neid oder wie
heißt es nicht dass ich mich da jetzt
noch verschreiben
freie presse rite charité auch schon aus
mit dem weiß
kannst du mir charité
in der kiste tun
danke
luca nein ich möchte am liebsten noch
ein herz hinter machen weil ich weiß
nicht dass jetzt mal danke luca nackt
war
nein so
du wolltest mir ja dieses eine kristall
zeit geben kannst du fraser in die kiste
turmberg ich wurde jetzt dem kev also
daran dann wo das schild steht hier
wohnt jetzt kommt crafter neben so dann
haben wir uns dann auch mal bombay
verewigt kurz nachgefragt aber cool dass
der das rot färben kann dann wäre ich
meins dann glaube ich irgendwie auch
werben
liebstedt ich ja irgendwie ein pinkes
oder irgend sowas hätte ich schon geil
oder 1 0 ein grünes aber obwohl brigitte
schubert hallo entschuldigung zombies
demba ba warum das denn jetzt alles hier
alter dicker was wollt ihr denn nicht
alle hier
ach so habe ich die mob falle
deaktiviert oder wie er kenne eigentlich
keinen krieg oder ähnliches tonnen oder
also da kann eigentlich jetzt gerade
nichts kaputtgehen
ich sammle nur eben ein bisschen
erfahrung
sprich ich stelle mich hier drauf lasst
die sachen dass bonn wo mein gott das
ist ein boss fritz könig den ich
theoretisch einfach irgendwie von
irgendwo weit weg abknallen also führte
machte gar nicht so viel schaden ja okay
ich mache auch nicht so viel schaden mit
meinen sachen hier damit mehr weil er
doch heftige rüstung alter und ich bin
verlangsamt tatsache ich bin vor langsam
was wollen die scheiße skelett kampf das
macht er so spart man halt einfach ja
ich glaube am besten wenn ich ihn eben
ecke gedrängt hätte aber eigentlich
sollte ich das schaffen
ich habe trotzdem bisschen angst
alter
ich habe echt ein bisschen angst ich
würde ich muss jetzt erstmal meine leben
auf land das kann nicht sagen wie stark
ist in der ich meine triebel rüstung und
sein heftiges schwer d'elegance wort
auch noch verzaubert und dann habe ich
hier trotzdem diese langsamkeit und die
ganzen pack egal jetzt wirst du sterben
musst du hin
und jetzt einfach ab ohne das kann für
wieder bei der unten ist ein schutz von
dem und ich bin so kacke verzaubert aber
hey des toten die das noch nicht tot was
soll das sie löst er habe doch schon
erfahrung bekommen
spontane seine kumpels oder wie ich hab
was ist denn das für ein typ
sorry leute ich will jetzt echt gerne
umgehen aufhören weil ich gerade mit
einem kampf bin ich muss es jetzt aber
mehr oder weniger ich jetzt ganz kurz
vom server herunter dann komme ich
gleich wieder drauf und dann patsch ich
dann eben zu ende
dort sollen die kacke hier egal da ich
jetzt eben runter ich würde sagen es war
schon mal ein zombie dass der rc kurz
dabei war und dann sieht man in der
nächsten folge wieder wo ich den typen
dann hoffentlich besiegen werde